so let's say this is you and this is
your time and attention that you have to
pursue any new opportunity so you say I
need seven income streams because the
average millionaire has seven income
streams so I'm going to spread myself
thin between seven different
opportunities and I'm going to wait
until one of these things takes off but
the reality is is not which of these
ones will work any of them could work if
you put the work in it's absolutely true
that people who are the wealthiest have
multiple income streams but what's not
true is about how they got there the
wealthiest people in the world go all in
on one income stream and they keep
adding it up over and over and over
again until it overflows they then start
diversifying back between the other
different ways but they made their
wealth focusing on one thing and then
they maintain their wealth by
Distributing it you don't make money by
splitting your attention up you make it
by focusing on the one thing that
matters most